[Music]
hey my name is charlie cox i play matt
murdock aka daredevil in marvel's
daredevil on disney plus marvel's
daredevil is a crime drama which tells
the story of a blind lawyer by day
superhero by night who attempts to help
people using both the law and
vigilantism and yet struggles with the
morality of his actions for me daredevil
represents the idea that sometimes small
day-to-day acts of kindness or help can
make big differences and instigate large
change over time people love superheroes
and what makes daredevil special is that
this character has to struggle and
sacrifice a lot in order to be impactful
and i think viewers relate to how
difficult making the right decisions in
life can be sometimes i'm very grateful
to have been given the opportunity to
play a character who means so much to
people who have perhaps struggled in
their life in some way or felt held back
by something in their life and to be
able to do it over the course of three
seasons and in the defenders to to be
given the opportunity to do it for so
long
was a great honor you can watch marvel's
daredevil now streaming on disney plus
you